burn rogen are two dudes that have said
throw away things to me that I've hung
my [ __ ] hat on Wow bursts at one time
if you something effective if you're not
challenging yourself then you're not
getting better and if you're not getting
better then why would anyone want to
watch you hmm
so I legit challenge myself I said I
said I talked to stand out and Stanhope
who says it was he was like he was
drinking one morning and he I was like
what are you doing he goes I'm right in
the knock-knock jokes
I don't what he's a camera and goofs man
like just goofs you know I'm [ __ ]
around I'm not writing material I'm just
just you know working with my work in
his brain yeah getting the brain to
really do something and he said we're as
funny as those guys right we gotta be as
funny as those guys I was like yeah he
said there's no way they're funnier than
we were we're funny so why can't we
write knock knock jokes huh yeah why not
and then I started getting obsessed with
noir McDonald he's a guy that could
write a knock-knock joke like he's a guy
yeah who could take a standard structure
joke and then and then make it now me
I'll speak I'll speak only for me but I
think all of us me you Segura like our
group of guys D'Elia
Santino ever all while all of us we do
what we do in our own way and but it's
not traditional stand-up right and I'm
not gonna get I'm not gonna go into that
like go into like I'm gonna do
traditional stand-up I was like I got
would like to challenge myself to write
a guy walks into a bar joke yeah and so
I did it and I think it's good and I
think it's probably the best joke I've
ever written but I don't think you'd
know it's a guy walks into a bar joke
until if I unless I told you and then
you go oh [ __ ] and so and like so I did
that I did that I tried to do this thing
about this gun bit which i think is one
of the better bits I've ever I've seen
that I've see I believe that I seen yes
I'd seen either but at The Comedy Store
man yeah I thought it was so good yeah
and so I just try to challenge myself
and if I succeed then I'm great you know
but if I didn't then if I didn't you
still got the stuff you loved what I did
and and I think these I think I look how
it's the exactly you said about your
special that's how I feel right now I'm
super proud of this [ __ ] thing but
like you don't know yeah I don't want to
be like some guy that's like and who
would I be if I yeah I think there's a
there's definitely a thing of learning
to be proud of things and then there's
also a thing of constantly okay how do i
how am i gonna challenge myself again
where
am I gonna move the bar am I gonna stay
in this safe sir take a look at where
you've challenged yourself look I heard
a joke that you threw away the other day
and I thought old Theo sorry someone's
told me this joke ago it was a throwaway
I brought it up feeling it's like oh
yeah whatever
and I thought old Theo would have hung
his hat on that joke and that would have
been his act and that would have been he
was that every night on stage where you
are today because you've challenged
yourself and taken [ __ ] big strides
now you're [ __ ] where you're at in
stand-ups next [ __ ] level but you got
it
we always challenge ourselves when are
you we were younger yeah always think
about it if you stayed where you were an
open mic or and you were like I'm
getting laughs that's what I'll do we
and we know those guys yeah then they
stayed here the whole time but instead
some guys you get those laughs and over
mics you're like I'm actually better
than those cheap laughs I got this yeah
the cheap laugh scare me now cuz
sometimes I want to tell a joke I don't
know something new to do yeah and I
middle don't say too much but I want to
do something new and I'll be like man
there's a couple of cheap jokes and I
really liked that yeah five eight years
ago I'd have been like oh definitely
no now I'm like I just can't do that
it's not gonna make me feel good dude
when we work together in in San
Francisco and you sat down and you told
like a solid eight minute story about
that Mexican man I went to school with
you oh yeah I'm on the floor you would
have never had the balls to do that in
what was like eight hundred people you
would never had the balls to do that
when you first started but you
challenged yourself and challenge
yourself and I think we have to keep
doing that as comics when we do specials
we can't just go well secret time worked
let me just do a carbon copy of that
change out the punch lines but same
structure a structure works yeah why
wouldn't I do that again well I think
it's I think is you know what I might be
thinking way too much about it I know
that little pine guys like ro gonna
probably like dude just be funny bird
birds birds even after all birds advice
he'd boat we'd be like bro just be funny
remember that's like the rule yeah if
you want to be you don't have to [ __ ]
sit here like a workout clothes I have
to save the world would enough to yeah
you have to be funny yeah but also at a
certain point you have to make yourself
laugh to are you yeah you have to are
you just not gonna care about it you're
just not gonna be unless you're a joke
writer if you're a storyteller that I
think it's different you know
we're storytellers and I think we take
people places and yeah a good
storyteller you you gotta like you gotta
figure out new ways I mean the way
you're telling stories now man no one's
doing it like you and and thanks man
what's the truth and everyone talks
about it [ __ ] everyone talks about it
and but but you didn't just show up with
that you had to work there right and so
why would you ignore that why would you
go okay I'm here I'm done I'll just do
this for the rest of this exact same
thing for the rest of my life but do you
ever think like oh I'm gonna be stuck do
you ever think though that I'm gonna be
stuck here like I'm just gonna be able
to do this or do you think like okay I
will continue to evolve do you ever just
wonder for yourself like will I continue
to evolve I think everybody kind of
wonders that like I would always the gas
tank gonna run out you know I feel like
that yeah cuz you know I get in my own
ways like excited travel channel for so
long and then when I got out of traffic
channel I was like I was I found success
in podcasting and stand-up and that was
it and I went [ __ ] it I'm done and I
literally turned a middle finger to
everyone in Hollywood and they'd be like
hey we want you do this I pass and when
you do this pass and then everyone came
at me with the project and I passed on
everything and then one day I went I
like I like I remember someone got like
a movie I mean Tom did a movie maybe or
something
I only say Thomas I talked to him so
much but like he Tom did a movie with
Marky Mark and I was like why would you
do that he was like well you got it you
got it try any stuff and I was like what
do you mean trying to strike wits who
what's Fox wants to be a movie with Mark
Wahlberg and he was like doesn't life
experience don't you want to try it and
then I was like oh yeah maybe I should
maybe I should also maybe I have time to
also do other stuff mmm and then I was
like okay like I'll do let's do a series
and so we did it we did a series with
Netflix
and then I was like I was like well
maybe we can do a sitcom I wouldn't mind
doing a sitcom and then I started going
like ham cool doing a movie also like
I'm not I can I can be in this Lane and
then do other stuff around I got in this
mindset where I look at you look at
Rogan who's our [ __ ] who he's our
Messiah man I don't mean that like you
know maybe like he's our guy like right
he's a template he's a template and he's
put us all over and gave us our all
amazing opportunities and every single
one of us acknowledge it but in
you also see that path that he carved
through stone for himself and you
realize if I stay in that path I got a
great life like I can just do podcast
just to stand up do spots at the store
The Improv the Icehouse and [ __ ]
there is room to grow yeah but you also
gotta go
hey man I'm also not Joe I'm not the
best listener like yeah I'm not the best
interviewer I'm I don't know what I'm
maestro there no I have no discipline
honest smart I'm not as smart like so
like so like maybe I should also try the
things that I'm also really good and I'm
saying that for myself
yeah myself to myself yeah oh I'm
[ __ ] I'm a window looking ninny like
I'm definitely nothing that you're not a
smart but yeah we're not as smart
I'm not Jill Rogan I'll tell you that
man I found that out many times the hard
way yeah Joe Rogan I think there's Larry
something in good evening good afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw I mean it was okay
but the next video you can watch could
be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watch this one